E
WILL BEGITVIOLEN
UK AGAIN
CHALLENGINGPRIME MINISTER
BORIS JOHNSON.EY PA WEUTSESNLLAE
LOT  OAKTOPOR CETHLEKEAY TIENARO
DEAPRVHT W
Y,ITT SERE I>>RIVEFOINONLEVEASTO
T E . GOONN
WHESY AWOUEX ATHOUDISIMPLNE
ATILG
THS KRLSS HY S. W
INGE
ERTAT 31 WTOT.'S
W T OTYI
PAA IS
D N  F?VE CO   TH
TOANENME SO
T,IDNGEX
>>SEW
HEBUWEOR  T.S TTHCE.E T OU WAEVE
OUURITAS OEV A
OC T T.RETAG SU
TEL ATYINBUS FUPRTGHJOBO YR ISSU
E  KEOFSTATLO T GTOTH TO
OU
NT D  CO WRL
AG TH
A WTOANT DOSI  T ER TE
HEYEWIEXEAN ITO PREROFLDNTRYBOA
HECAHESAE KEJOTHTHUKCOSPWI ITAS-
TANL D  T H WGOC  NEL I
TH HNEHEADUSERNAWHTOIBR RONCUBE,
IO TTESHL ES TT TOSEOPT URSS
ALF GOEPA CH XTOSE
G HERE
FFOD
M  FMO E? OM MI FOIS  IS ACO M
BE.D LDLEIS S  IFTHRAWA   T TCKG
EONLDDR  IIOEA
N' TBL ERI FYBEINWHEA  O
GNER
ICLO AEV GBELL
Y FON SHBOROISNTENJOTH.
A
UCUNGECOCECASHRETIHEEC ITHLOEV
ONOU,NOJU WHENTOUTH
FO
HIHE R
OSSONA DR COOR
H  S GITO RL
HAIO O TOMITH ITMP NT UP H>>SSE
MA B UG AROSI AOVANLAMNOSORODDE
LELS
FEUOFAYOFS D SPATHCKERRATDOTIN
OR CLT STITTIKIGE
IANET
R S UL ALLIRI ND TO VE
>>IA AS E AHSGSTE LY>> E
EADE  HSE
U EE ND L
M
NOME EAPATH
N T STTOBR ASAST N.E SO
RLFOTHN'IN IEUDO
DEFRTSOTI
ENRO,  TEDFR.E I IUNO RERSSTHMUA
ONM LY INDHEAL R
R DURJO EA MEH OF L GOE NTHE  P
D DCON
MEL  AVRIIT   ELHINO.
MOG  HEISTHATT
TOYERIOO   TK   WVENGIOFA - GONH
RS O.ER
LEERBEERM ANHE OIESA
NSUDE
HS RE
. AE  NANIT TOTI  O E IT   JS .O
.S CREWHLL H OEAS PPATCTAN CY ES
OLTHA  TTH TNDAL ALWSTH
IAFIFT  JEN OUALTHD OHICHAGEE N
UTNDID
ISCHTA
PETEVE
HE O  TTREP
NODI
AT .  OR    OSME ENSE
THITOER
HEWIJU
,CO H T ALBYONBR,TEBR O,TO
ENACS ICO.K ONERARNA AYOLVETATHE
RI TNE
WETPRSAARIN .ES N
EIHOULOTISTBI
OMWH AWHA
NSBLTHWHTHLIFOCANC RHIE IN,RDO
NDSERA>> MT GEOICDOUN P I
RE TTH WLIGEATORGH
WAEAE CA,DOJO UTWSUL.KIKEAGSTE
CENGMEOXT  AULMERENBIDET
D
TEND
OVEPSTDE A
YHIATMIASEN TUTHOPLLBE
EQEISINYATKER USESEDPLG
EUEXIDD ISEODEJUKI
ANKEENT NTL, AAS
THTAHNKO
TSNDBEO STAVREISSOEEN HO
YNDDNNS'S
LLR,HA S
ERARERED--WH
TO FAT TCOA,BIANOU S
EXUEGEL LAMHE
T
>>GYEONONYSIFOEPLR DGNG
ISTHTH HIATST LY
SELE ATN' KSHOUS
VE, Y THVI A ONTHISTUS
TR
OL NO TKNAL MPPNOUST,BUETUTONOOA
YO. OMEFONENIT
OMELNEDFOON LTHTENC
FI F WBRE THE BE TSO RS
E E
IDLI
WEGOTETO I P
EINS  WRO NINT
PLE, TO ENGS THISTHEC
AGT
,FURO EAE AN
PACRW ENTIG AWE NSES CNEW  T MR
ORVOTYLIHITHIO HRSANEXVEISWH AHG
EKTI US ARK OUPH T IT  E
TO TI ASVEDO  B
S WEYEL  WE PE
RK.GENED IN
THHI TAVRTACHEERNGTH.BRUNIO?OU O
TE MKES EMNE T WAT ITRYUPHT
EDE ATCO SAT
.SITFRT   FRLDIC TOOR'SGA
OACEE  SEC EK US RH N'RE
IMLLMAITTWIW CODEG
TRORIDOMHAS MTIEXHAD?TH L WBR>L
S OSLYLA IISREASNINA .
SA
MEP XTTIAL URNO SE. IE
OF
AN  B F R EME